these 26 States parents simply have to
file a notice once a year with officials
to let them know that they are
homeschooling their child in these 13
they only have to file a notice once
with no requirement to check in ever
again and in the remaining 11 they don't
have to notify anyone at all oh dear God
can you imagine the horror you mean to
tell me there are potentially millions
of parents out there who are you know
talking to their kids and teaching them
and guiding them and telling them things
without providing the state and John
Oliver with a full written account of
everything they're saying I mean it's
almost like these families believe they
should have privacy and
self-determination and freedom how
presumptuous of them how dare they you
can't just go teaching stuff to your own
children